how's it going everybody it's Warren and
it's an exciting time to be alive with
phase four of the MCU having already
started and phase five not too far away
and it seems like each day we just get
more and more information about the
upcoming movies and Disney Plus shows
coming to phase four and five not too
long ago at Disney's d23 event they
announced three new series coming to
Disney plus she-hulk miss Marvel and
Moon Knight at this point we don't
really know too much about these series
coming to Disney Plus we don't know much
about she-hulk we know that miss Marvel
however has begun casting and it appears
that Moon Knight has already begun or is
about to begin casting as well and
apparently they have one actor on their
mind to play Moon Knight and that is
Daniel Radcliffe Harry Potter himself
this may come as interesting news but
we'll break it all down in this video
quick reminder to subscribe and
notifications turned on and leave a like
on the video and comment below so you
can enter my giveaway for a chance to
win an Xbox one or ps4 so as of right
now if you've heard the rumor the same
thing is kind of happening with Daniel
Radcliffe that happened with Robert
Pattinson when Robert Pattinson was cast
as the Batman many fans had a hard time
seeing him as something other than the
sparkly vampire Edward from Twilight
well it seems like the same thing as
kind of happening with Daniel Radcliffe
a lot of fans have a hard time seeing
him as something other than Harry Potter
however that seems to be only a minority
of people and many fans tend to be
pretty excited about this choice
according to full circle cinema comm
casting from Marvel Studios his upcoming
new Knight may soon be underway and
Daniel Radcliffe is one of the actors
that Kevin Feige in Marvel Studios are
considering for the role of Mark Specter
aka Moon Knight full circle cinema goes
on to say that Marvel Studios is
searching for a Jewish actor to play
mark Specter because in the comics mark
Specter is Jewish and Daniel Radcliffe
fulfills of this requirement his mother
is Jewish and he's been very vocal in
the past about his heritage being a
central part of his identity so right
now it seems like Daniel Radcliffe is
the frontrunner for Marvel Studios to
play Moon Knight
now Daniel Radcliffe is a very talented
actor he's done many different movies
shows and plays outside of Harry Potter
and Harry Potter was really good as well
but is he the right person to play marc
spector
aka moon night well let's take a look at
the character Mike Spectre is a Jewish
American rabbis wayward son as an adult
he joined the Marines serving in force
recon but afterwards he left the Marines
and became a mercenary occasionally
doing work for the CIA
mark would eventually become a very rich
man doing all of this mercenary work
however while doing some work for the
mercenary Raoul Bushman in Egypt the
group stumbles upon an archeological dig
site there they had found the digging
crew which included dr. Peter all rune
and his daughter
Marlene all room the dig had uncovered
an ancient temple where artifacts
included a statue of the egyptian moon
god khonshu of course bushmen wants to
loot the dig site for himself so he ends
up killing dr. all room after bushmen
kills dr. al roon marc spector
challenges him to personal combat
however bushmen ends up defeating marc
spector and the crew leaves him there
for dead the egyptians who worshipped
the ancient gods fine specter and carry
him to their temple and put him in front
of the statue of khonshu spectres heart
ends up stopping and khonshu appears to
him in a vision offering him a second
chance if he becomes the gods avatar on
earth Specter wakes up and he wraps
himself in a silver shroud that covers
the khonshu statue he finds Bushmen and
he ends up challenging him again
although this time he defeats him he
thing goes back to America with the
doctor's daughter Marlene and decides to
become a crime fighter he models a suit
after the silver shroud that he took and
becomes Moon Knight aka the first of
khonshu now what some people say about
Moon Knight is that he's Marvel's
version of Batman and he's honestly not
that too far off he's a vigilante rich
crime fighter who dresses up in a cape
and a costume
although khonshu did grant him
superhuman abilities such as superhuman
strength speed and stamina
now Specter goes on to create multiple
different personalities as I mentioned
he becomes wealthy so one of his
personalities is a billionaire in which
he calls himself and identifies as
Stephen Grant the other is a taxi cab
driver who he calls and identifies as
Jake Lockley now he ends up going insane
and at one point he doesn't really know
if khonshu was actually real or if it
was something that he made up in his
mind and that's something that Kevin
Feige actually mentioned at Disney's d23
event does he have powers or is it all
on his head
but I can actually see Dan
Radcliff playing a character with
multiple different personalities I think
he would definitely have to bulk up a
little bit because Moon Knight is a
pretty big character but overall I think
Daniel Radcliffe could do a very good
job as Moon Knight so it makes sense
that he's the frontrunner for Marvel
right now but let me know what you think
about this are you a fan of Daniel
Radcliffe and do you think that he could
play Marc Spector aka Moon Knight let me
know your thoughts about this in the
comments down below also don't forget to
like the video and subscribe but
notifications turned on so you can into
my giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
one or ps4 winner gets to choose and I'm
picking a winner at five hundred and
fifty thousand subscribers also click
the link in the description down below
for a chance to win an Infinity Gauntlet
that giveaway ends the end of this month
don't forget to use code cosmic @ G fuel
comm for 30% off G fuel and as always
thank you all so much for watching we'll
fluff
you